Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Three Scary Games
We're gonna start out with a game called Tonsil Terror.
Now this might be the most... "innovative" game?..
I hesitate to say innovative because I'm gonna assume this is gonna be weird.. (you assume correctly, Mark)
I-it's a game that's built off of you screaming.
And me, I'm a good scream guy. (Yea you are -.-)
I know how to scream rEaL gUd
I know the screams..
I do scream. I scream real good.
I-I, you don't play as.. a human, I think you play as.. a tonsil?
in a human?? (where else would the tonsil be Mark?)
And- wait, you'll see. Alright, you'll see what I mean, just a second..
Okay I think I've got the scream level where it should be, so I'm gonna start this.
okay, like I said *giggles*
You're um, a-uh
AHAHGHAGHHA
*giggles* AGHAGHAHA
*continues to giggle* you-you're a- ...god! It's connected to your microphone
so *proceeds to scream* YAHHHHHHHHHHHH
*laughs* I gotta play real close up on it
*laughs*
I GOTTA PLAY REAL UP ON IT
OKay so THEEE.. *giggles* YAHHHHHH
*won't stop  laughing*
y-I gotta go set it a lil lower
Okay-okay, I don't wanna be screaming into a *screams*
*laughs* SO what you uh, WAGHGG- what is-?
*stares in confusion*
*just screams*
(Mark i think you're havin' too much fun wit dis)
YAGHGHGHG
(Yup, way too much fun)
*screams in fake terror*
OHH NOO- so you're looking for-
so you're looking for candy here.
so you're looking for candy a-and uh, I can barely see- YAHHHHH
oooh.. and the only defence against the ghosts is screaming.... AHHGHGGG
... hello ??
HELLO EVERYBODY MY NAME IS MARKIPLIERRRRRRRRRR!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
well that didn't work ;(
apparently that didn't work-k-k-k *laughs*
alright, so what I can also do is, I can bind it
I can bind it too, umm a button? Oh, both! Oh both is good. Both is good. (reaL gUd, MArK)
okay! We're gonna do both
AHhhhHH *weak* aHHHH *weaker* aHHhh *weakest*aHHH
So we got- *screams* AGHHHHH
*game continues to scream while Mark laughs*
*giggles* oh this game's great
oh wow
aH
No no no no no nonono ahhhh
aww *giggles*
So really once the guy gets you, there's really no... way to go about it
For educational use only!
Yes. I assume this game is very educational about the interiors of a mouth
Ok so I'm assuming I'm supposed to-
*giggles* -assume I'm supposed to run away
That's a can- That's a piece of candy!
CANDYYY?!
OhH BOY!
*eating sounds* ahHmnumnumnumnumnum
oh
Really?
It just gets stuck in my teeth?
Uh oh
aghHHH
*laughs* This is how I'm supposed to do this?
AHHHH
What am I supposed to do??
*quietly laughing* What am I supposed to do?
Am I supposed to-
Is it like- Am I not screaming loud enough??
Cos I'll scream louder!
I'll do it!
I'll hurt m-
This is the WORST first game to start
Is a whole day of recording that I'm doing-
It's the worst first game because this is gonna blow out my voice
*giggles* Like at the very beginning of the game
UHhh ok, alright, I can do this
*singing* YAHHHHH
*slightly higher* YAHHHH
I wonder if it's like- BAHHHH
*sheep-iplier* BAHHHH
This is gonna- Everyone cover their ears
This is gonna be-
*inhales*
NUHHHH
NUHNUHNUHNUH
NOOOONO
*continues to scream-sing*
*scream-singing* OHHHH
This is not- that can't be good- that can't be
aaHHH
uh oh
uh oh uh oh
AHHHHHHH
*giggling* there's no- I can't go faster than that! What am I supposed to be doing?
AHH
WOHHH
YAHHH
YOOO
*slightly higher* YOOOOOOOO
YAHH
OHhhh
DUHhhh
They don't like the screaming
Ohhhh
So I'm supposed to just be nice and calm
AHHHHHHH
Candy
YAHHHH
Ok so
AH uh
AHHH
Ah I'm getting it now
AH
And it flashes when there's candy nearBYYyyYYy
NAHHHH
I think? Maybe not
YAHHHH
No?
Oh
HIIIIIIII
OOOOOOO
AHHHH
Oh
AHH
I guess he won
UHP
Yeah I see something
Here we go
Ok
AHH
How do I get that?
DUH
AHHHH
Alright
Ok
AHHHH
Uh oh
Hey bUHdy
How you doin'?
Nonononono
Nononono
C'mon
AHHHH
Where the f-
There we are
DUH
DUH where's the-
There's a hole in the wall
DUH
EeeEEEh
AHHH
Uh oh shit oh shit oh shit oh shit oh shit oh shit oh shit
Ok
(Mario) Ima fine. Ima fine. Ima fine. Ima fine
I'm fine
AHHHH
Ok
I don't think this is how I'm supposed to play-
AHHHH
-the game but I'm playing it this way
Alright here we go, here we go, here we-
AHHHHH
Oh dead end. Nevermind
DOOOO
DAHHHH
DUUHHLELE
YAHHH
I wish I kept the button on now
DAHHHH
DAHH
DAH
AH
Oh
AHHHH
AHH
UHHHH
Ok
AHHH
I have no idea where to go
YeeAHHHH
I wish I had-
AHHHHH
I wish I had kept the button on!
Oh I love the..tonsil physics
Or the..uvula physics
That's what I really want out of a game
Good uvula physics
HEEEYYYYYY MACARENA
Anybody?
HAAHH
HWAHHH
AHHH
AHHHH
Ah ha!
I see one
AHHHHH
DAHHHH
DAWAAEE
BAHHH
DOHHHH
AHHH
Here we go
Perfect
FOUR of eight
AHH
hnDAHHH
AHHHH
Five
They're really gonna get me this time
I don't know how or why
dAHHHH
I don't know
AHHHH
Is there candy here?
Candy??
AHHHH
dAAHHaH
CANDY?
No?
I don't know where I'm going
AHHH
AHHHH
What's down there?
doOOOAHH
Or did I come from down here I don't remember
AHHHH
Ooo
AHHH
AhhAH
OOAHH
yOOOOO
dOOOOH
Ohhh I see
I went in a circle
dOOOOHH
Let me get real up-
BUHHHHH
*realizing he's screwed*
AH ah I'm fucked I'm FUCKED
ahhh they're so everywhere
They're everywhere
Do they move even when I'm not- AHHH
Ohhh yeah they do
Ok
AHHHhhhHHHHH
Ok I gotta stop this game just for my own sanity, but that's funny
That's a clever mechanic
What can I say? I got a little bit of a sweet tooth
I got a sweet tooth!
I'm gonna try another game
Alright so this is I-sa-belle
Now I don't know what I-sa-bell is about,,, buuut we're going to find out
Am I waking up again?
Ohhh I am. Ok
Cave this time! No comfy bed for me
Ohh! It's a bright sunshiny day :)
Did I fall in a hole?
Oh hello
Alright. Woahh
*hearty chuckle*
Someone give me a can of beer! I've got my good weapon here
Hello?
Oh
ehh
Oh another tomb,
*MarkiMumblesTM*
Who's laughing at me?
WHo's laughing at me?
You know who the hEll I am >:(?
You better NOT.
I mean, you better- yes. (what)
I mean, you probably do- I don't know :/
My name is Markiplier an' no matter what..
... that's t-who I am. Hello?
*creeeeeeak*
.. thought I saw some movement there.
Can I pick this up?
Hoh yea I can ):3
Does- *giggle* -this is like, no light at all.
I might as well not be having this...
aalright
well this is moderately creepy
So, who put all this stuff up here? This definitely isn't a MINE ):T
*the face of intense spoop*
did i hear something??
*the face of questioning*
aalright
This definitely isn't a MINE
*footsteps, MarkiMumblesTM, & spoopy ambiance*
*clik of failure*
No, not yet anyway...
-alright.
I can't sprint so this is my maximum speed-
-unless it's gonna get to a chase sequence and then unlock sprint for me ;D
Which is something with these douches who make these horror games sometimes won't do :((
oH hello
What a.. what an ugly key.
I mean I'm sorry, I don't usually insult keys that way
but this key is just.. butt-ugly.
whatever..
here we go
*another clik of failure*
kerCHUnk
Just that easy, huh?
*will there ever be a successful clik?*
Can it-is it open?
*yet another failure to open a door, Mark's confusion, & spoopy music*
Is it open?
*FINALLY* Ahhh-I gotta right click.
Okay, I get it
*creakk*
Okay-
So far so oDD..
Ohh, sh*t-- *the face of nope*
Oh hi!
Ah no thank you I don't want- I-I-I-I bought girl scout cookies already ;-;
Hello
How are you?
Oh, another tomb!
Surrounded by weird floating skulls! Perfectly normal~
*the sound of our lord satan himself*
Hi! Oh- there- why- and do I need this?
*nope face 2.0*
I'm gonna assume that I do
Even though I haven't needed any TOmbs up until this point-
OHHh grandma!
Hi!
How you doing? Hey,, grandma come back D':
C'mon
Your back ain't so good. You should lie down.
Oh that's sunlight
Oh I can't see anything that way, I'm not gonna go that way..
Now what do we have here?
Hello?
Oh!
Good!
It's locked! And I didn't bring the key!
So is there something down there?
*Marki mumbles*
GRANDMA?
I can't see grandma!!
*Michael Rosen*
NO GRANDMA!
Did you say you could smell me?
I know I haven't bathed in a while grandma, but that doesn't mean you need to call me out like that...
I don't know where uh-
There's something there. There IS something there *detective mork on the case*
I need to go get like a candle or something..
.. or maybe one of these skulls.
I can put a candle in, make a nice candle holder.
Ala the forest
okay
weird
I highly doubt that the key is gonna be the same key across the board, but I guess there's no harm in...
...bringing it
Just in case
Aaand it's gone
Ohh that's right it would be gone because it would've-
it was stuck in the door
So let me bring... *flame swoop*
Let me bring this at least
It's gonna help a little bit anyway
I dunno
Spooky :0
I don't know who-
What am I looking at? I can't see anything :c
oh oH OH grandma! You didn't tell me soup's on!
Oh boy, grandma!
Oh I see a key
Kay, I see it
I see it right there
Ok
Alright
I got a key!
I sure did! I sure did!
I got the key, here we go!
Right in the hole
Imma go and grab that candle
I ain't gonna be left alone in the dark anymORe
Heh
Ok grandma!
I'll come back I ain't hungry right now
I know, I know, I'm all skin and BOnes
Skin and sweet, succulent bones
But uhhh, hard pass grandma
Ugh
It reminds me of the-
the inner caves from The Forest
What am I- Just gotta find keys and unlock doors?
Y'know the one where if you get caught by the cannibals, you wake up in the-
in the cave
Those cannibals sure are very forgiving...
I don't like these-
*terrified silence*
No
I.
DON'T.
WANT.
YOU.
O-
K
So the ghosts around here throw tantrums,
and throw these chairs all willy-nilly like
Ok...
I can't carry both of these so...
Here we go then!
I would like to state for the record that I hate this
I just want everyone to know that this is the worst
I just want everyone at home to understand that I DOn't appreciate what's happening here
IT'S TOO QUIET!
WHY IS IT QUIET?
*scared squeal*
Ok there we go
Easy-peasy just like- *terrified mumbling* -nothing!
It ain't nothing!
Oh!
Hehe!
Oh the way out!
I'm sure that's good!
I'm sure I won't be stabbed in the back before I go home!
Oh boy, a dusty tomb!
OHhh
I didn't know I could read these
"Don't turn around"
*terrified inhale*
*rambling in terror* AH DON'T WORRY I'LL TAKE THE ADVICE. I AIN'T GONNA TURN AROUND, I KNOW BETTER THAN THAT
...EVEN THOUGH I JUST DID
Ok. GOODBYE!
Goodbye?
*nervous laughter*
AH! My ankles!
OH! Uh oh
Well that's not- that's not good
That's-
That's not good
That-
AH!
GRANDMA!
GRANDMAA!
Grandma why you do that to me!?
I know I didn't eat your sOUP!
But that's okAY!
Alright fine, grandma! If you're gonna be that way!
God dammit
I knew they were gonna do that but...
Why'd you bother grabbing my ankles like that huh?
Aaalright
Oh! This was made by a Twitch developer? Oh that's so cool!
Someone made this live- live on stream, oh that's cool!
That was really neat-o
A very basic horror experience, but sometimes...
basic horror is what you really need 'cos that did it,
pretty well. I mean,
it- it's like not
*tongue tied*
It's not innovative in a lot of ways, but it IS
very true to form of good horror.
Like it created the environment, it created the slow pacing...
It didn't really give me instructions on what to do, but I could figure things out
I didn't know I could open the books from the very get-go
Because I didn't understand the controls
But at the same time,
Like even though I got it on the last one, which was important so,
there you go
Heh
Heh heh heh
Ah heh heh hehh
Next!
*Ariana Grande reference* Thank you, next!
Alright, now bare with me 'cos the title's real weird
Ssseven
Uh-juh
Seven
Seven uh-juh seven
Suh-VEN-uh-juh-seven
I.
Am not.
suPPOse
to stay
in this
home. stay.
It's
haunted
She trying to kill mee in mY DREAM
I need to GET
the. hell
out
of. hERE
oh. plEASE. GOD. HELP. MeEE.
*ASMR time* God can't save you now buddy...
Oh
Oh Megadeth! Metallica, Metallica
SomeBODY likes...
music!
"nothing's here"
"not sleepy yet"
Eh, that doesn't seem right
Ok...
What is it?
*giggling mumbles*
Hey, wait a minute!
Hey!
Hang on a second!
If I know a thing or two about ominous glows coming out of my own house,
That's probably a bad thing
Also why-
-why does my door not go all the way up?
Oh well whatever
Woah-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho *fades into giggles*
Ok. Alright. Well
I'm uh-
I'm waitin'!
I'm waitin' to be wowed- woOoo
Aha
Whooo-?
Who do I live with?
3D game art for phOne and Unity
"It's a radio"
*Enter Sandman by Metallica starts playing*
No! Copyright! *giggles*
None of that. No thank you!
Eh fffOOOp it's locked!
*turns music on and off again*
Ok. Well
Might as well go to sleep then, right?
What do I gotta-
*inhale of terror*
Heh-
Waaaiiit a minute
What are you doing?
What's going on?
Uh!
Oh
Oh!
Well
Alright then! I guess that's...
all there is
"It's a sink" You're right, it is
"Nothing's here", "Nothing's here", "Nothing's here"
"Nothing's here"
Ok, I got a whole...
house full of nothing,
which is always good
Huh
That was moderately dis-concerning! And I kinda like the fact that it didn't
pay off into a cliche jumpscare
God dang it!
Dang- woaaaa
*exhales in disbelief*
Reallyyy?
I've got a keypad to a door in my own home
Ok
Alright
*high pitched* I'm down for that!
I'm down to clown for that!
Ok
Alriiight
I'm d- woah
What? Just that one drawer?
Just-jus-just this one drawer. With just- just that one. Thank you. Ok
Alright
Anyway, I'm down to clown!
"Not available in this demo"
Oh! This is just a dEmO!
Okaaayy...
A demo huh?
Alright then...
"Umm maybe not"
Umm maybe yeah! My bladder's about to blow!
Anybody in here?
Maybe like there's clues in the- the...
the environment or something?
I don't know
Ooo!
Hello!
Five!
Five, baby!
Gah! That's a five!
Oh hell yeah!
"Nowadays people prefer scrolling their phone rather than reading books...Sad but true"
Oh my God!
This is our- I'm 14 and this is deep!
Five books here- ooo!
Nine!
Oh!
Wo-Ohhh!
Wo-Oohhhhh!
Wo-OOoooh!
Wooooo!
One!
This is the greatest mechanic- *gasps* There's another one!
What have we got?
Heh, lemme crouch down here- nope. I can't. Pick her up. There we- THREE!
Ok
I. am. on my. tOOTsIEs
The tippy toppsies of my tootsie wootsies
I am so ready,
for whatever the hell this is getting in me- in store for
Let's do this, baby
What else we got?
I am burning up this place
In here?
Nah not yet nah. We'll save that for later!
Ohh!
I am just RILED up to my testes! Here we go! C'mon, what do we got here?
Ok
Good
Great
Love it!
Love it lots!
Super love it!
Lo- wah! There it is! There we go!
Love it!
Love it lots! Just one more
On the kitchen table, you know it baby, I go-
*game jumpscares him while he inhales in fear*
Fu- oh God! I didn't even know!
I didn't know! I didn't know!
I was here making jokes!
God-
Dammit!
Damn you! Six
D- you think you're just gonna jumpscare me like that ya douche?!
It's always the simple ones because I get lulled into a false sense of security
God dammit
59...13946
Ehhnter
T- Ohhh my God that was it!
*game's ending music plays as Mark stares, questioningly*
Ha! Ha! Ha!
Alright!
Ok! Alright!
No!
Nope! Nope!
Nope! No!
J-nope!
Nope. Nope. Listen,
Listen, listen, listen
That was fine,
That was fine
One jumpscare...
That's fine
BUut,
I don't think that was quite enough, so I'm gonna do one more game...
just because...
I think it's only fair
So we're gonna do ONE more
'Cos that was only worth like one jumpscare, so I can't really say that that was,
a proper trial of a game
So, this one's called "Nosferrratu's Lair of Doom"
Made byyy, good ol' Dave Microwave
Oh no! Plot!
Okaayy
*mumbling, trying to make it sound like the character's talking*
*reading the character dialogue with a magNIFicent Russian accent*
Wait! Why would you go in alone?!
*now with a Texan accent* Why you gonna go in alone? We came here together. Why not stick together?
Split up is bad! You go in alone, you dIE
How do you even get to the top of the bell?
Oh no
He's so brave!
Look at him go!
Wow...
Oh!
Well shit!
That's- that's a prah- That's a problem!
*chuckles* Why'd you go in alone?
You went in alone! Ya doof!
Ok
Well then
Oh! Heh, I'M the idiot!
Oh!
*Russian accent again* Vell
I suppose I'm in trouble
Well why does that keep happening?
There we go! Much betterrr
Alright! Well let's do this! Whatever-
Just gotta get to the top of the castle?
Is that all we gotta do?
Is that you, Nosferatu?
Okaaayy, I don't know how to get to toppy top
Ok I suppose I'm- ohh creaky
Alright then
Is this all I gotta do?
Hey! Who ah you?
Who ah you?
Ohhh
*spoopy noise* HEY! WHY? WHY? WHAT DID I DO?
I DIDN'T MEAN TO DO IT!
WHATEVER I DID I DIDN'T DO IT! IT WASN'T ME!
AH! I- didn't mean that
I don't know why you thought that that was a necessary thing but y- Oh! Someone...
Someone did something naughty on this floor! ;)
Ok. So I gotta get to the tippy top again
*scared squeal*
...and signal for help
Woah
*Russian accent yet agAIN while reading*
Ooooor...
Or you could climb up the bookshelf
Ooo!
Hello!
*Russian accent* Ho ho! I could take this latter, put it on that latter!
And make life a lot easier if you ask me
I crouch!
I mooove this!
Kaboo- *panicked muttering* HEY! WOAH, WOAH, You can't crawl under here can you?!
Naaah you can't! You idiot! You ssstupid piece of poopy!
Oh you so stupid! But you did wedge me in here...
God dammit! You wedged that back in there!
You sack of shit!
That was probably my only way to victory!
You piece of poopy! I hate you!
Look for a small glowing chest. Do a bit of puzzle solving and platforming then?
OH! AYE! WhhYY
LET'S- LET'S- You don't have to! You don't have to!
YOU DON'T HAVE TO! YOU DON'T HAVE TO!
NOOOOO
I'm fine!
I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm fine
Up this ladder! Up this ladder! Up this ladder I go!
Does he follow me up here? I have no idea
Did he give up?
Yeah he gave up 'cos he's an idiot!
Yeah that's right!
Uhh! (don't take this out of context)
K
Where am I? What's with these Minecraft blocks?
Oh, hey
How's it going, Nosferatu?
Alright well that didn't help me
OH! HEY! Wha- whAT?
Hitler??
HITLER??
Is thaT HITLER??
That might be- that- I think that's Hitler!
Is that HiTLER??
That might- that mIGHT be Hitler
I thINK that's Hitler
Eh, why is Hitler up here??
Ohhh Hitler please
I don't know why you're here. I have no idea but ok. Alright
Thank you- for the- your interest but nO
Oh shi- OH SHIT!
H- I've been grabbed!
I've been graaabbed!
Oh- th-thank you? I guess?
Oh
I found one- I've been graaabbed!
I have been grabbed by his big, strong hands!
He's just gotta grab me
I guess
Wow
He's so big and he's so strong!
Alright. What is this?
Where am I now?
I have no idea
That's so funny...
Ok. Huuuhh
Uhhh, why? Why did that happen?
I mean it wasn't terribly scary but-
AH! WHY? OH MY GOD
OH MY GOD! HITLER NO!!
I'VE BEEN GRABBED!! I'VE BEEN GRAAAABBED!
I got webbed and I got- OHhhh I got w- OHhh I got goop all over me!
You were the one that made that mess on the floor!
You asshole!
God damn you
God damn you!
Oh, you're still gonna be there aren't ya?
Alright well then come on, graaab me
Grab me with your big strooong arms
There's nothing in any of these
There's no reason to go in any of these
This is a whole lotta nothing
A lot of dick, a side order of diddly, and a whole lot of nothing
There's the place where I knocked it over but I can't go- Oh!
Ladder rungs!
Don't. Do. Anything.
Hiiitler, come on!
Ah! I've been grabbed!!
I've been graaabbed!
Ughh
Alright so I gotta get back down and I gotta put these ladder rungs on the ladder...I think
And then that'll be good. I guess
Where am I now?
What is this place? What is tha- oh!
Oh
Ohhh
Oh it's a laboratory
Oh it's a lab- ah! Hitler!
No
Unless you're Frankenstein
Are you FrankenstEIN HITLER??
Oh no!
Ok
Or no- Frankenstein's MONSTER
Frankenstein's- ahh shit!
It's Frankenstein's Hitler
Ah I've been grabbed!!
I'm graaabbed!
Somebody saaAaave me!
Oh well
Poop
Poop on my...face
Ok
NOOOOO
I got- ah!
Screw it
Screw it. Screw it. Screw it. Screw it. Screw it.
That's enough of that!
We get-
We get one short,
not so good game, and then half of another game
Ah it's fine though
Anyway
So that was 3, and a half, Scary Games
Hope you guys enjoyed it!
Thank you everybody so much for watching!
And thank you everybody so much for being here! If you wanna check out some cool clothing,
I've got Cloak, which is Sean and I's clothing brand. You can check it out for yourself
It's got a lot of cool stuff. A lot's sold out right now
We've got a charity stream on December 1st!
Be there, 10 am PST
Everything on my Markiplier.com store on that date will be sold for charity. I won't make a penny,
and you can help support a great cause for Stand Up to Cancer
Thank you everybody so much for watching, and as always, I will see you in the next video. Bye-bye!